bonsoir camilla genovese merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
quasiment un an jour pour jour après le
premier confinement l'italie se re
confine retour au point zéro
ça veut dire c'est un bon soir donc ça
oui c'est ça ça fait bien non lundi
c'était dedans oui le neuf le 9 mars on
entre en confinement pour la première
fois en 2020 et là le 15 derniers à
nouveau en confinement du moins la
plupart des régions italiennes sont
compilés on nous appelle des zones
rouges dont les déplacements sont ne
sont pas possibles sauf dans en cas de
nécessité ou de travail
les autres régions sont des zones orange
ces des zones quand même qu'ils ont
beaucoup de restrictions
il n'y a qu'une seule région l'italie
qui est zones blanches c'est-à-dire où
il n'y a pas de restriction et c'est la
sardaigne la sardaigne est pardon pardon
une décision qui inquiète plutôt bien
accepté par la population à ce qu'on
imagine que le moral est pas vraiment au
beau fixe 1 1 un an après de retourner
comme ça dans un confinement très strict
ça doit être très compliqué à vivre pour
les italiens c'est ça c'est ça c'est
surtout les jeunes et les parents qui se
retrouve à nouveau dans une situation
avec leurs enfants à la maison
les
on se retrouve la plupart des italiens
pensent que voilà un an est passé et on
est toujours la même situation beaucoup
se demandent qu'est ce qu'on a fait
cette année pour se retrouver à nouveau
en confinement mais c'est vrai que il le
faut il est nécessaire dans cette
situation de nour confiné afin de
limiter les comptages à quoi doit-on ces
mesures très strictes c'est un mesure de
précaution ou selon vous les chiffres le
justifie vraiment alors c'est vrai que
il faut toujours essayer de prévenir
enfin ce qu'on dira italie c'est
prévenir c'est mieux de traiter donc
c'est vrai qu'avec une augmentation des
comptages qui maintenant est arrivé à
25000 countach par jour la pression sur
les réanimations et sur les services
hospitaliers augmente sur les urgences
on augmente aussi et en travaillant avec
des médecins généralistes
on voit aussi que les contes les cas
augmentent même les absa symptomatique
mais aussi les patients qui doivent être
gérés à la maison augmente donc c'est
quand même une pression qui est de plus
en plus forte sur le système sanitaire
c'est la faute aux variants britannique
où la faute on relâchement des
restrictions selon vous un peu des deux
je crois que c'est un peu des deux c'est
vrai que ben il ya une augmentation des
cas qui sont dues aux variants on voit
ça en emilie romagne j'ai dit que
beaucoup de cas sont dus aux variants
c'est vrai que avec le beau temps qu'on
a en italie
beaucoup de monde se retrouve à
l'extérieur au 6 mai et
mais c'est vrai qu'il est nécessaire
voilà un certain moment il faut il faut
essayer de limiter comme on peut la
population générale va essayer de
devenir en aide aussi aux soignants
alors des déboires aussi un pas que chez
nous en france des déboires sur le plan
de la vaccination puisque mauvaises
nouvelles en italie aussi astrazeneca
était suspendu c'est évidemment un coup
de frein dans la campagne de vaccination
c'est ça c'est sa belle c'est une
nouvelle d'aujourd'hui
astrazeneca a été suspendu par la fifa
c'est l' agence italienne du des
médicaments
voilà un nom bardy les vaccinations est
en train de ralentir a un petit peu avec
ça on verra quels seront les effets sur
le long terme du moins dans les
prochaines semaines et dans le même
temps on apprend que ce footing mais on
l'a appris il ya quelques jours allaient
être produits en italie c'est c'est un
espoir pour le pays oui c'est quand même
une opportunité est aussi ça nous permet
d'avoir plus de vaccins qui sont très
nécessaire en ce moment parce que c'est
vrai que on en a mais pour commencer à
vacciner le plus de monde possible
vous savez être la couverture vaccinale
pour retourner à vivre normalement ne se
limite pas à bach signer une ou deux
millions de personnes donc le plus de
vaccins le mieux les médecins réagissent
comment l arrivée de ce vaccin russe est
ce que la confiance est là bas nous on a
confiance dans la science et on sait que
si les mae life a donc notre agence du
médicament approuve le bac ça on fait
confiance à ça et on sait que qui serait
sûr pour nos patients et pour le collège
voilà merci kamiar genovese médecins en
italie merci d'avoir été avec nous pour
nous exposer la situation sur place